et c'est bonjour alors comment se passe
cette première journée de déconfinement
pour les commerces
eh bien écoutez amira ici tout est mis
en place pour respecter les consignes
sanitaires et les gestes barrières on se
trouve ici dans une boutique de
vêtements à senlis
tout commence à être dès l'entrée avec
ce passage obligé la désinfection des
mains au gel hydroalcoolique la boutique
ici est divisée en deux pas plus de deux
clientes par surface à leur victoire
bonjour vous êtes la gérante de cette
boutique racontez nous un petit peu le
protocole que vous avez mis en place ici
on va écouter comme vous l'avez dit le
gel hydroalcoolique avant tout après on
a également les petites lingettes pour
désinfecter la machine à carte bleue
pour l'essayage en cabine on a condamné
une des deux cabines pour pour le pour
les gestes barrière j'ai fait un beau là
pour la distanciation pardon est l'une
des deux cabines nous servira à mettre
les vêtements à quarantaine qui sont
essayé on a également les petits
produits désinfectants qu'on vaporise
dans la cabine après chaque passager
dans la boutique le soir on va également
désinfecter nettoyer tous les soirs on a
une partie qu'on met dehors
habituellement qu'on a rentré pour pas
que les gens touchent sans être sans
avoir les mains désinfectées
et puis je pense que les gens après font
de même
les gestes qu'on leur qu'on leur demande
de faire depuis le début quoi est-ce que
ça a été compliqué pour vous commerçants
de mettre en place ce protocole est ce
que c'est simple à appliquer est ce que
est ce que c'est pas trop flou non plus
appliqué c'est un peu un peu flou parce
que déjà les masques sont pas bons on se
demande si on lui rend obligatoire ou
pas
on sait pas trop combien de temps les
vêtements doivent être mis en
quarantaine
à part ça bon c'est juste un peu
désagréable apportée par exemple pour le
masquer mais bon sinon c'est pas des
pins faisable ans et on va s'adapter de
toute façon on n'a pas le choix
alors quel état d'esprit êtes-vous on
imagine que vous devez ça va être
salvateur ça c'est réouverture ah oui
par contre c'est comme vous dites
salvateur ça fait des mois qu'on est
fermé c'est sûr que c'est dur à tenir on
espère que ça va repartir et qu'on va
pouvoir avoir la trésorerie nécessaire
pour la suite les opérations mais bon
après c'est c'est toujours un plaisir de
réouvrir de retrouver nos clients et nos
petites habitudes parce qu'on avait
avant merci merci beaucoup à victoire
voilà à l'erreur pour cette première
journée de déconfinement ici dans cette
boutique de vêtements à senlis dans
l'oise l'ouest qui se trouvent en rouge
sur la carte du sd confinement et qui je
le rappelle a été le premier foyer
d'épidémie en france
estelle merci pour toutes ces précisions